while varenga spent 10 months alone in a
tiny boat with absolutely nothing Jose
alvarenga dance Ezekiel Cordoba had
landed almost 500 kilograms of fresh
fish but then would a weather change
wave after wave rammed and slams their
solitary skiff fearing the careening
catch could cause them to capsize
alvarenga made the difficult decision to
dump the lot overboard they passed the
rest of the storm huddled inside the now
empty ice box with the fishing gear gone
alvarenga got
developing a method of catching fish
with his bare hands the two men also
caught seabirds and turtles after
consuming a meal of raw seabird Cordoba
passed away and yet against all the odds
alvarenga flung to life day after day
month after month for a staggering
438 days